what if you have a daughter
are you gonna force her to wear the
hijab and everything
and what if she doesn't want listen to
me listen to me clears that listen to me
Islam not force anybody to cover his
body or wearing a God but you do or not
it's back to you we're not force anybody
to do anything but then why do you force
her to change the way she dresses
uh I'm her husband and she's between
here and me it's not your business
so basically it's what I say goes or
nothing else
I told you this is going to be between
me and here so basically you're going to
talk to her listen to me
I will talk with my wife about that and
we were a fan if she can do that or not
or I can't accept that or not
it's such a weird thing it seems like
such a superficial thing to care about
right but I think it feels bad to me to
have to
be told what to wear when to wear it
like that I have to are you going to
teach your child if you have one that
they are you going to make your child
stay true to this Faith you are now
are you going to let them choose their
own religion or are you going to force
it on them I didn't say they don't have
choice but like I said I will teach them
how to be Muslim house and then they
choose will they will they go to quranic
school here Nicole I'm not sure I don't
have any kids right now so
let me let me ask this If This Were a
Jewish couple saying that their kids
would be Jewish this was a Christian
couple saying that their kids would be
Christian
why you said forest forest forest like I
don't like what bro you literally forced
her to do everything you suppress her in
like behind closed doors so don't even
say you don't force her to do anything
because you do he's not like an idiot
like
honey it's okay it's okay
um
sweetheart just tell yourself I'm done
when he's challenged he walks away shut
up us
[Music]
thank you